[Music]
[Applause]
alrighty uh we head to Augusta Mike
tariko Sunday Night Football
play-by-play calling the Masters for
siriusx and where are you right now Mike
right now Dan I am in one of these
Studios for SiriusXM which is in the
Press building at Augusta so I think we
do the show from one Studio down by the
way is this the DP show now projecting
that embiid is one of the MVP is this
like it's like cornacky on Election
night we can now project all the
precincts aren't in yet Mike but uh
we're gonna project right now that Joel
embiid is going to be the MVP all right
give us an update on the weather
uh great today good tomorrow uh bad the
rest of the week cool and windy and as
you know Dan from your years being here
wind here is Multiplied because it
Swirls and you have to be so precise to
Landing spots so wind here is very tough
and cool usually that brings in more
players in the field and it's not about
overpowering the golf course or for the
big hitters having a big Advantage it
becomes everything's a three shot par
five so if it's playing like that those
are the years we've seen Zach Johnson
Mike we are among others win so it may
bring more guys into the mix come the
weekend what do you read into Tiger's
comments
which ones about uh the golf ball about
him about about him with his future yes
his future he's more of an open book
than he's ever been Mike no doubt Dan
remarkably reflective and uh Taylor
zarzoo I'm working with on SiriusXM did
an interview with tiger yesterday and I
was driving to the course this morning
and heard it and I was thinking the same
thing that you just mentioned remarkably
reflective you know and I guess when you
have to
um really go through all these major
surgeries you nearly died uh you're
going through all these major surgeries
and all of the rehab none of which we
really know the lengths that he's gone
to you have to do all that just to be
able to play again but many people think
you couldn't play again uh let alone all
the back stuff
at some point no matter how Invincible
you seem to be it has to make you a
realist so I think he is very reflective
understanding that it takes a lot to
play here
and if he's got one or two more or three
more whatever it is to savor and
appreciate it and it does make all of us
I think feel old when we stop and say
this is Tiger's 25th Masters because you
know it feels like not too long ago when
we watched the early ones and then 97 of
course yeah I was there for his first
one wow that's crazy isn't it I know and
it used to be tiger versus the field mic
and we rotate tiger
you know a lot and and more often than
not be right his winning percentage is
still extraordinary his winning
percentage in the majors is out of this
world uh you just reflect on his career
and the career of Jack Nicholas and that
I saw them standing next to each other
jackseeded Tiger standing in the picture
that came out from the Champion's dinner
last night and uh it's just remarkable
to see tiger set that Nicholas standard
as his goal and almost got all the way
there didn't get all the way there with
the six Green Jackets and the 18
professional Majors but got pretty far
along that path and it's one coolest
thing I think about golf is that
Nicholas played he was inspired by Bobby
Jones had the chance to play with Hogan
and then Palmer and Watson and Nicholas
and now they pass it on to tiger and
Tiger's passing it On to the Next
Generation the connectivity of golf
because the longevity of careers brings
that history really to the surface I
think better than other sports help us
under stand tension level if there is
tension between live and the PGA Tour
how big of a component is that going to
be with your coverage this week boy I
thought it would be more from just the
feel for the week and I think it's been
diffused pretty quickly I think the guys
got here and it feels different now
maybe if the US Open or the PGA was
first
it might be a little more knife's Edge
and it may be a little more tension but
I think nobody wants to be the guy who
was at the Masters and made it about
live versus the PGA Tour and not the
Masters Tournament it just doesn't feel
like the place to do it and it sounds
like from the early reports from the
Champions dinner last night uh that the
guys mixed in pretty well and it wasn't
an issue there wasn't a Kitty table for
the live guys and everybody else got to
sit at another table you know uh it
sounds like the six Masters Champs who
were there were part of the evening and
it was there all in the name of honoring
Scotty sheffler which is pretty cool
okay aside from tiger versus Phil on
Sunday in the final group I want you I
want you to be program director here
give me the ideal twosome on Sunday
afternoon
yeah um there's a bunch because there
are a lot of good guys right now like
I'd love to see Scotty sheffler trying
to repeat let's see John Rahm trying to
win here because he's got everything two
in here you'd love the Nostalgia of
those guys but I would take Rory versus
Jordan Spieth uh Rory going for the last
leg of the career grand slam the only
one of the majors he hasn't won
against the guy in spief who has that
crossover magnetism that I think other
guys don't and you know what I'm talking
about Dan like there are people who
don't love golf but they'll see Steve
and they'll stop and watch because they
know there's an entire dramatic
something he's going to break somebody's
phone hit it off of somebody he's going
to be in an impossible place he's going
to chip in and make three and just kind
of have that aw shucks look about him
right there's something about Jordan you
want to watch him hit his next shot and
I think Rory's got that star quality uh
along with everything he's done to try
to keep the PGA Tour intact uh you've
got to have Rory versus Patrick Reed on
Sunday
really do you want that now that who's
who's not going to be rooting for Rory
other than Patrick's friend but nobody
roots for Patrick Reed anyway even his
friends probably don't yeah but we need
a villain there you you want to go that
way yes yeah okay how about this how
about Dustin Johnson and Rory yeah but
you know what Dan like does anybody
dislike Dustin Johnson or does anybody
dislike Cameron Smith most of the guys
who are playing for live or playing on
the live tour when they come back it's
like yeah you know what did he ever do
to you right now Patrick Reed has over a
variety of years I don't know I might
get sued here if I say anything about
Patrick
um
over a variety of years he has caused
the ire of several for a variety of
reasons always been very nice to me but
this is uh this has been told in courts
over the years
but other than that there's no villain
amongst that there's a villain in
general with Norman with Mickelson and
the idea of live but by the way look
competition's been great for America
competition when when you were at CNN
and we were at ESPN you know it was like
okay what sports tonight do you know
what that that makes everybody better
and I think the existence of live has
made the PGA Tour better
personally just personally where I sit I
had a hard time with the guys who helped
their careers
achieve where they got
because of the PGA Tour and turning
around and publicly saying I want the
PGA Tour to be harmed or fail that's the
only place that I said ah you know what
to me as a golf fan that's not cool
other than that
competition makes you better I think the
tour is better today than it was 15
months ago because of the threat of
living
is Greg Norman there
I I have not seen him uh he certainly
wasn't at the Champion's dinner he
didn't win the tournament I doubt he was
invited to come otherwise
um I don't think that the 18 live tour
members will be waiting around if one of
the one of their Brethren wins the title
like if somebody shoots 75-74 misses the
cut I don't think they're going to hang
for the weekend to welcome him off the
18th green so well that sounded good I I
don't I don't see that happening I hope
it does it'll be good theater but I
don't see that happening and pretty had
a joke if you want to use it in your
coverage on SiriusXM that uh okay he
could see where you know some of the
Live players don't show up on Sunday
because they only play 54 Mike just
saying that's good that is very good
yeah they will have guys finishing the
Masters on seven like you have a live
tour and there will not be a concert
right after uh that will not be look
it's different it's um it's a challenge
to the system
like every other thing think of think of
the ABA and the three-point shot right
the NBA thought that was ridiculous that
half court shot that Jerry West hit in
the in the finals was a two-pointer to
send the game to overtime right it would
have been a three to win it back uh if
it was more recent the aba's ability to
do that changed the game and impacted
the game forever so there are there are
elements of stuff that can work it's
it's just what are you playing for are
you playing for a championship or you're
just playing for cash and it doesn't
feel like you're playing for anything in
a sport where what you're playing for
and the legacy of the sport matters
probably as much as any sport but also
Mike if you look at the live tour
players they got paid and they get to
play in this major how many majors are
they going to be able to play in each
year damn that's the big story with
those guys the numbers are going to
dwindle because they're not getting
world ranking points uh unless you have
other ways in you're not going to find
your way in so each major has a certain
qualification if you finish in the top
12 or the top eight you get invited back
next year to me that's the story with
the Live players on Sunday uh are you
going to earn a spot into next year's
Masters or somewhere else if you win by
the exemptions that come with your
finish so to me that's one of the small
stories but I'll have the most impact on
individual guys whose ability to play in
these Majors is going to run out as
their world championship points run out
and also their qualifications for
winning the events that they won guys
like dechambeau and the US Open et
cetera et cetera and Captain as well
what uh what's your best score at
Augusta
I don't know I I'd have to go look I've
only played mine come on if you've only
played a few times if you knew no if it
was really good I would know it yes yes
then it was it was all about what's
yours 81. 81 wow and would did you find
and for the you know for the people who
have had the opportunity to play from
the members tees it's very playable it's
not very long and it's it's really if
you have a good putting day or you're
accurate you have a great caddy you have
a chance to put up a good school but we
played wherever you could play from the
tips we played from the tips oh you did
yeah we ate 18 played from the tips uh
wow yeah but you know there were a
couple of holes but my caddy uh caddy
for sevi and wow what a story and he was
wondering I got traded on the First Tee
Mike
because the caddies were betting
oh oh and and I got trade I hit my tee
shot and and uh my caddy traded for me
and so they had money on us that's while
we're playing but the best it's the best
part of it I I will say that this did
happen to me at Augusta closest I came
to an ace in my life was here at six I I
came I was playing with Jay Bellis as a
matter of fact it came this close to an
ace that was the uh that was the golf
moment of my life at Augusta now what do
you do you have to buy
drinks for everybody in the clubhouse I
don't know how that works at Augusta
sadly I never got to find out oh yeah
and you don't even remember what your
score was Mike no I don't I don't do
that Dan I don't walk around talking
would you get a hold of billis we're
already on it billis will have the
scorecard because he probably shot a you
know pretty good score no he he he did
play well that day I have the picture of
how close the ball came the caddy said
Mr Mike we you can't have your phone out
but I got to take a picture of how close
you came and I do it's this close it's
painful thanks for bringing up a nice
memory for me Dan
appreciate it
fire real behind you by the way uh it's
yeah I mean it's a it's a it's a it's
real warm
when I when I worked the uh the Thursday
Friday coverage with ESPN that Scotty
Van Pelt does now although the question
I would get from people more is the
fireplace in Butler cabin right now yeah
yes it is real it is but see you should
have gotten like some marshmallows
yeah that that would be great come on
Butler Capital excuse me Curtis and I
are just speaking of sports here that'll
go they they have a great sense of humor
down there Mike what what do you think
about the whole location at 13 today
Curtis hang on I don't want to roast
this marshmallow to it I will say this
Dan for folks in all seriousness and you
know this because you've been here
working and you've had the opportunity
to come as a guest
uh media member player caddy Pro uh
guest uh Patron as you know we'd like to
say here all of it it's really hard to
get here when you get here there's no
place in sports where you get treated
better they treat everyone great the
Press building here they should buy
fiber bring every sporting event into
here and have it covered from here uh
they do everything really really well
and uh
[Music]
no I'm not I'm going home on Monday I've
been here for 11 days don't you agree
though yes yes yeah it's it's an awesome
place it really is it's one of those you
do Pit yourself when you get here it is
pretty cool you understand why people
get emotional about it I have a pimento
sandwich on me Mike okay you want me to
send one to you no
okay I never had a pimento cheese
sandwich until I went to Augusta and
then I went where's this where's this
been in my life
the best thing ten dollars beer sandwich
and chips and you can come back with
change yeah go back with change where
else do you know I took a piece of turf
from Augusta when I played
did you like try to put it in your life
I brought it back for you I brought it
back in tupperware and my wife goes what
are you doing and I said I I brought
some grass back from Augusta and I was
going to try to see if I could plant it
it didn't work and I didn't I've got
I've got a quick one for you okay last
game at old Tiger Stadium uh they were
handing out cups of dirt from The
Outfield warning track and we were
building our house in Michigan so my
wife grew up a tiger fan we have a cup
of dirt from the warning track at Tiger
Stadium left field in the foundation of
our house in Michigan there you go um
well there you go thanks for topping me
Mike
thanks for topping me
nice to talk to you again I miss you
good to talk to you that's Mike tariko
Mike will be the lead play by playboy
SiriusXM Masters broadcast tomorrow
through Sunday at two Eastern each day
also he'll uh he'll be part of golf
channels comprehensive live from the
Masters Studio coverage as well starting
this week at noon Eastern